i've heard uh a phrase it's like
basically what rich nerds do on the
weekend everyone will be doing in 10
years right
yeah and that's exactly what this is
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want
[Music]
on this episode we are talking about the
bar stool sports drama dave portnoy
versus the world we have a billy of the
week this guy brian johnson who to me is
kind of like the elon musk you've never
heard about we have two business ideas
one around an e-commerce idea and then
another one for restaurant
drive-throughs and then we end with a
funny story about this dog walker that
went to sam
and we play a little game called how
much is pomp worth where we guess how
much our friend is worth because he just
gave back all his investors their money
and he's just gonna invest his own money
from now on so that's the episode hope
you enjoy
did you see sean that people were
tweeting saying they liked what they
liked hearing what ben had to say and
then he retweeted that
as he should dude i retweet every
compliment not every comment but if i
get a bunch of compliments
like if i check my phone and there's a
bunch of compliments in there one of
those is definitely getting retweeted uh
yeah i think it's obnoxious when other
people do it but i also
notice it and so i'm like oh this is
effective obnoxious but effective
we uh
we have some cool stuff to go over today
but the coolest one
is the dave portnoy stuff
yeah let's talk about this i've been
wanting to talk to you about this same
since it happened and it's still
happening so that's great it's like
there's just more that's come out and
also i think you surprised me because i
think you're not i thought you would be
so pro dave portnoy and i think you're
actually not from our text messages so
first
explain what happened
and then we'll we'll debate it
okay
so let's start with if you don't know
who dave portnoy is dave portnoy is the
founder of a company called barcelo
sports they're basically known for like
smut bro comedy that's actually pretty
genius and i'm typically a fan of it
it's like if espn was drunk this is what
they would this is the news they would
make
yeah exactly um that's a great way to
describe it
and
dave portnoy is a he's what this isn't
an insult but he's kind of like trump in
that he's like ridiculous and he's got
fans that will do anything for him and
he plays this part that's exaggerated
and silly and
and just overboard and everything he
does um so the business insider released
an article last week on friday or
thursday coincidentally right when bar
stool which is owned by a publicly
traded company had their earnings call
they released their article at the same
time and it basically was an eight-month
investigative journalistic piece where
this woman named julia black spoke with
loads of people who had sex with dave
portnoy and this is basically
him or her or both
the girls
dming dave and dave had there were
screenshots that said something like do
you want to be famous if yes i'm a good
place to start so like saying like some
silly ridiculous douchey stuff and the
women saying like i would love that yes
i'm in and they have sex
no problem
but
in the article some of the women accused
dave of having basically rough sex
nothing like illegal i believe was he
was being accused of but basically like
saying like he spit in my mouth i had to
wear a leash he filmed me things like
that not illegal
then
hearing this dave gets livid
and he goes on a scorch earth war mode
where he goes after business insider and
he mocks them because their founder
henry blodgett years ago got in trouble
with the sec he goes after our friends
morning brew
because they are owned by business
insider and he is just going
crazy on everyone and the fans
of dave portnoy are attacking these
people like crazy and it's become a
little bit of a frenzy and it's pretty
wild that's basically
the summary right yeah i'll fill in a
couple of uh tidbits so so dave is what
do you need to know to admit to having
to have an opinion on this so dave is
not married he's a single guy i think
he's in a relationship now but like you
know he's a bachelor right so he can do
whatever he wants he's a rich guy he uh
he's just
he's in his 40s and so there's always
this kind of like it's not illegal but
is it wrong thing when it's like a guy
who's 40 something i don't know what is
he 44 or something like that one of the
women was 18.
uh 19. 19 i think yeah 1920 something
like that so you know there's always
this sort of thing where you're like uh
okay it's not it's not illegal but is it
right you know some people have an
opinion on that all right but whatever
he's known for
being like
um
like
i'm not like a loudmouth but
he speaks um he doesn't like pull any
punches so he's direct he uh
i think he's a fairly honest guy
um and he's honest to the point of uh
fault sometimes so for example
the news the news story hits what a 9
out of 10 people do especially ceos of
companies presidents of companies he's
not the ceo he's like the chairman or
president
he um you know you're supposed to sort
of lay low
your publicist will release a press
release that says you know we
categorically deny any wrongdoing
um you know the truth will come out
and uh and you let it blow over and you
hope you didn't get cancelled he did the
opposite so he comes out immediately on
instagram live or it's instagram ig tv
and he just says look my lawyers say
don't say anything but i'm going to say
exactly what's going on here um so
here's the deal these guys have been
i've known for months these guys are
putting out a hit piece because they
contacted like
dozens of people that i've been with and
they said they're fishing for something
bad about me and then these people would
come tell me hey dave you know there's a
reporter asking around for you know if
if you know if you've done any wrongs to
me and i said no because you haven't but
like just so you know this is what's
going on so he knew this was coming
finally it drops he addresses it
directly and he said he basically turns
it on them he said you try to cancel me
i'm gonna cancel you and so all of a
sudden on twitter
cancel business insider uh is is running
because he's like look you're trying to
profit off of this story you you act
like oh which is part of the story which
is
this article is paywalled it's payable
and they're sharing it like crazy
they're putting tons of ad money behind
this come read this story about dave
portnoy the bad guy we are exposing the
bad guy but you just gotta pay 9.99 a
month if you want to read the story so
he's like dude you're using my name and
likeness you made up this story where
there's nothing wrong um
you know these are consensual
relationships with legal adults
um you know he's like i feel bad if
somebody felt bad after we hooked up and
they they didn't like me or they didn't
like what that they did it like okay
that's that's one thing but this was a
completely legal consensual thing what
are you digging up here what are you
trying to say
and then he goes on the he goes on the
offensive whereas most people are on the
defensive he goes on the offensive so
he's getting people to cancel their
business insider membership he's getting
people to unsubscribe to morning brew
unfortunately a bunch of people started
sending death threats to our friend and
people who work there and that's not
cool
and he's like go buy my pizza my pizza's
out in stores let's go
go buy a p there was another angle to
this by the way that really pissed him
off so i think he was a little bit mad
at the hit piece and then i think he
went scorched earth once
the there was a reporter for business
insider that started reaching out to
barstool's advertisers and saying hey
are you aware of the story we wrote
about how bad dave is and and business
and at bar stool like you know would you
like to comment on being an advertiser
on their platform basically trying to
take money out of their pockets trying
to get the advertisers to to to cancel
their relationship with barstool which
is
not
journalism at that point that is like
warfare as far as i'm concerned and it
is warfare as far as dave is concerned
too so that's when he went really like
nuclear
so all right and let's let's say a few
more facts here and um a few more facts
i'm gonna try and be as factual as
possible but you know i'm gonna be i'm
gonna paraphrase
at one point he did a
live thing on youtube and he made
jokes but i don't know if they were
jokes where he said something like
you know i think i'm gonna hire a
private investigator to go and follow
every single morning brew employee and
find everyone who they've had sex with
and see if there's any dirt there right
and
what else has he done that that we
didn't say that was like part of the
facts well i guess we should say what is
the the sort of the the the crime or the
wrong doing so so
the business insider article made it
sound like
a girl goes to his house knowingly that
dave wants to hook up hooks up with dave
feels shaken up about it afterwards
because it was kind of kinky and crazy
she sleeps on the couch she leaves and a
few days later she tells her friends
that she's feeling depressed and
suicidal and uh
and her mom i think is the one who
went and reported to the police and said
dave is a bad guy you guys need to be on
the lookout for him and the police are
like wait what did he do
um
you know and it's like and the mom's
like he's i went to the fish market and
they said that he's here with a
different girl every week
and it's like all right you know being a
player in a crime you know that there's
no crime here ma'am like i understand
you're upset that your daughter
you know had a bad experience but that
is not a crime you know and in a
follow-up on his feed he tweeted out a
picture that she sent him afterwards
that said like i want to get with you
again he he basically leaked the dms and
the dms were basically like
they hooked up
okay she slept on the couch then she she
shared a photo online of her with dave
kind of like to get the attention from
her friends and whatnot on social media
to get the likes uh you know her kind of
posing next to dave and then also you
know he was like you know do you miss me
and she's like ha ha yeah and
you know she's basically they're like
planning their next hookup you know and
it you know never happened so he kind of
he he sort of the insider article made
it look like he traumatized
slash you know almost raped these women
but then he released the dms which were
basically like them joking around after
the fact and saying uh
you know
you know do you miss me uh you know when
are we gonna hook up again blah blah
blah and the girl's definitely like down
as far as the dm's got now that's not to
say
it wasn't like you know
a bad experience or weird experience but
again that's what the allegations were
so
that's what that's what came out now i
wanted to get your take on two things
one is
this offensive versus defensive strategy
what do you just think about this in
terms of the art of war so what do we
learn from something like this because
cancel culture is everywhere i think you
and i both don't like it we don't like
the general
quick trigger that exists with cancel
culture and how like
how that's just becoming more and more
common uh for a variety of reasons
but then how do you deal with it what's
one to do so so what do you think about
this offensive versus defensive strategy
there's two parts to the story there's
like the actual deed and things that
he's accused of and then there's the
reaction so in terms of like
i think
from
just the article it's clear he has done
nothing illegal
um i don't agree with what he did and i
personally it i find it to be a sleazy
and unethical move that said my ethics
don't exactly to hook up with somebody
much younger than you or what bothers
you
i think that's weird yeah i think i
think a 45 year old fooling around with
a 19 year old i think that's a little
weird um but but
i think p that's people's right to be
weird right the law there's a clear like
cut off you could do what you want right
you're not putting me in a leash in bed
but if that's your thing that's your
thing there's that who you gotta say
i don't want my daughter to be part of
that i don't want my family to be part
of it i wouldn't i wouldn't do that to
people and i don't really want to be
friends with someone who does that
so i don't agree with it i don't want it
in my life but
people can do what they want as long as
there's adults who are consenting that's
cool
there's a difference between
you did something wrong and need to like
you know not have your job or your
company needs to suffer and you need to
go to jail there's like
your reputation needs to be besmirched
versus i don't like that behavior i
don't want to do it myself and i don't
really want to hang out with people who
do that right those are two totally
different responses and what you're
saying is more like the second one which
is i don't want to do it and i don't
really
think it's cool i don't want to hang out
with people who are doing that
but you know you're not saying that
uh this guy's a trash bag
totally uh well
i don't know if i'm do i think he's
trashy yes totally
totally i do but that there's nothing
wrong with that right yes just because i
don't like it yeah there's nothing wrong
with that you know everyone can live
their life
straight bullet
here i had to hit her like that
so i do think that he's trashy but
that's his right you could do that now
the reaction i think is totally
inappropriate uh and i think it totally
makes him look
butt hurt i think it makes him look weak
i think it's a bad move the reason why
it's a bad move is because dave has fans
and he could be like well you know i'm
only maybe he could say he's only joking
maybe he could say
um
you know i'm not saying that i'm gonna
do something bad right but i didn't
believe this until i had someone close
so we're i'm friends with the morning
brew guys and i see how i actually they
didn't explicitly say this but i think
that they're fearful that something
bad's gonna happen because dave's fans
are gonna go after them i actually
believe that might actually happen and
because of that i think that like when
you have that great responsibility and
that power of these crazies so we'll do
whatever you say you have to act careful
and i don't think that he's being
careful i think he's being harmful
additionally the guy a lot of the people
who work at that company morning brew is
just like my company it was like
dumb 24 year olds who are like talented
but like
inexperienced at life and don't know how
to handle a lot of like stuff because
they're still learning i saw dave like
tweet at some of the young people who
worked there and i was like
i mean this this guy is just an instant
bystander he didn't do anything wrong
why are you making fun of him i think it
was i i agree with you i think it was a
big mistake
to go pick on the little guy he had it
right at the beginning when he was
picking on the big guy oh business
insider you're you're trying to ruin my
reputation you're trying to hurt my
business and my advertising my revenues
and my my name and you're trying to
profit off that
it's
a good move to go after business insider
the brand the big name the ceo of that
who's like you know some 50 60 year old
guy who's rich and successful you know
okay that's fair game um but when he was
going after morning brew
that's a different company bro like
that's a this is they didn't even that's
not who wrote the article just because
they own this asset like
you know
that doesn't make any sense if they own
a rental property somewhere you're gonna
go deface it like you know that doesn't
make any sense so
i thought that was a bad look and i
thought that picking on those founders
who didn't say a word against him
picking on the employees of that company
now you're punching down and so i think
that was his tactical mistake in this
art of war i liked what he was doing i
also disliked the which is
like hold on stop there yeah stop there
swinging below that's the rule here
swinging below you can't do so like when
you're trying to create an enemy you
always got to go up right you always
have to go up if you go down you're a
bully if you go up you're david yes
exactly uh and so he he had
he had the momentum on his side because
he had um
you know he was the one being picked on
he said i've done nothing wrong and he
has fans and he could have set mobilized
the army if he had stopped at cancel
insider go cancel your membership over
there because these guys are just trying
to make a quick buck on the salacious
story that would have worked um that
would have been you know the good
version of revenge and then he went to
the bad version of revenge okay so
that's the offensive verse defensive
let's say that something happened to you
and um you know would you do you think
you would go on the offensive uh
or would you be a lelo kind of guy
offensive
offensive for sure
yeah i think it's good to go on the
offense
even though uh like i guess have you
ever had a situation like this come up
where you had to kind of go on the
offensive
thank god no uh i don't think so i don't
think so
uh okay
good
i'm glad
if you ever need to go on the offense if
i got your back because that's the other
thing he did it all himself whereas he
could have had other people kind of go
to bat for him and create a little bit
more uh not just one man versus the
world um i also see you have a business
idea here what is your business idea
wait i do there's one under here i don't
know did you write that maybe some maybe
ben wrote that uh it says it says
business idea twitter beef as a service
is that you oh my god no that's not me
but let me wait let me tell you one one
thing or there's some more facts here
this story that is actually quite
interesting so
a publicly traded company bought bar
stool like uh they bought part of it
like two three years ago maybe a year
ago i forget exactly i think recently
they announced they're gonna buy the
rest of it so
how much uh of bar stool does
is made up or how much a pen the owning
company do you think does bar stool make
up
ah that's a hard question i don't know i
know the answer okay yeah go for it
i think it's like eight percent
so if you like in terms of like revenue
and value what's pens uh what's pen's
market cap
nine billion
okay so bar stool was bought for 600
million i think i think and their
revenue is probably 100 pens is probably
like
uh five or something like that whatever
it's a so it's a small percentage
however
barstool makes up a significant amount
of the like brand equity of pen right so
like no one has known i mean very few
people knew about pen it wasn't they
don't they it's a regional casino yeah i
believe it's regional it's like on the
east coast now it's a global name
because of barstool and because of dave
so i would argue that while it only
makes up five or ten percent of the
actual metrics for business it actually
um accounts for like
60 70 80 90 of the brand equity
so here's the thing
the stock went down i think 30
the other day when this got announced
in my opinion i wouldn't want to own
this stock necessarily because i think
more of these things are going to happen
however i think there's a the pen is
actually an interesting buy right now
because if barstool only makes up like
eight percent of the their business and
business is doing pretty good the
business of barstool the ad business
would have to go away almost entirely
for this to make up like a meaningful
impact and yet the stock went down 30
this might be a good stock buy right now
i was i was looking at the map it might
make sense to buy this stock stock
market sam i love it stock pick at the
end of this segment uh yeah yeah i just
i think i think that's probably right uh
i think barstool is is uh
this is gonna go away and you know this
20 dip that it's taken is not uh
that's not
that's not a permanent thing
but i would say um
a not financial advice before we get
sued and b
um
i think that this is gonna be something
you see over and over again you see it
with dave chappelle right now he's going
on the offense uh you saw with others
would they just disappear they'll lay
low for a bit right louis ck or you know
the different different people who got
canceled and they go disappear for a
while then they come back two years
later and they sort of beg and
apologize and try to get back in the
good graces of things
i think that uh i think that going on
the offensive is gonna become much more
the norm and uh you're gonna see you're
gonna see that now he is perfectly
positioned to do this because he is like
you said a trump type of character he
always speaks what speaks his mind he's
always kind of you know off the cuff he
has devoted die-hard fans that will
believe him even when he's in the wrong
they'll back him up and so you know i
think that that was uh
that was working in his favor here if
you're the ceo of pen how do you feel
right now and what do you do
i don't know who we should look him up i
can tell you his name is jay he's a
young guy his name is gonna say if i
could just look at the person i can
figure out uh no it's jane jane ciccotti
or something like that yeah
that's what i mean jay or he's like a
youngest guy he looks like he's in his
mid 40s maybe it's a girl jane
the ceo of pen yeah ceo of penn national
gaming jane
skagetty or something like that
well for the there was a guy who oh yeah
i see you tomorrow the guy that you see
his name you see jay snowden yeah he was
the guy who was like uh
he's he's the president and chief
officer and director of pen gaming since
2020 i don't know what's going on i
don't know why they have two okay
whatever um you know i think they're
probably like you know a bit nervous
about this whole thing but um you got to
know who you're getting in bed with when
you buy barstool you know it's coming
with the hair on the deal and the hair
on the deal is
its greatest strength which is that you
know the
the big personas
the no [__] given attitude towards
content well they're using this content
also he turned he turned scandal into
more content but do you tell dave to
chill to cool it or do you just stay out
of it entirely you got to have them find
the line right that's what i'm saying
we're saying we're showing some points
where he crossed the line in the wrong
way so there's like you know don't turn
this into an actual legal problem and b
um you know make sure you're doing this
strategically in the art of pr war here
you need to be punching up not punching
down you need to be don't stick your
your you know don't do do you teach him
an incident
you teach him or do you say dave you
cannot do this again strike one like do
you are you disciplining him or
i think you're good
you're getting in the car you're sitting
shotgun with him you say okay look i
know how you feel right now
and normally we would say this but i
know you don't want to do that you don't
want to just kind of hide away and let
this thing blow over okay we're on board
but let's set some ground rules right we
want here's how we want this to end
right it's like a negotiation with a uh
with somebody who's got he's taking
people hostage it's like how would you
like this to end
um you know do you want to get out of
here do are you trying to hurt people
what are you trying to do and okay i can
help you get there you want a pizza let
me order you a pizza right now you need
a car you need to get away car how about
you let someone out and then i could
work on that car for you um that's
that's the way i i would be talking to
dave if i was uh you know jane cicada
dude these businesses when you when you
buy media companies hubspot did it with
us and we're not anywhere near as
extreme but when you like this whole
thing of like every company is a media
company when you start getting to that
territory i think it's good but a lot of
people do it not realizing that these
are some of the consequences right
yeah you're in the media all the time
all right let's do another let's do
another segment i got some ideas for you
i i wanna i want to do some business
ideas so
i've been looking at um
i've been looking at a bunch of
e-commerce companies and i'm in
e-commerce myself plus
invested in a couple and just friends
with a bunch of store owners and we look
at kind of the numbers and i look at
some business that are doing well some
of them are not doing well
and i wanted to share with you an idea
that i have that i don't know if it's a
really dumb idea or really smart idea i
can't tell you okay you tell me which
one do you think it is okay so in
e-commerce
e-commerce is amazing because there's
way less friction you don't have to go
into a car drive to a store
spend the time you don't you just you
can be on your phone on the toilet
you're shopping and you push two buttons
and hey it's gonna arrive in two days
that's kind of a magical amazing thing
what's the one downside
well for the the downside is it's hard
to know if the product's any good or bad
because you didn't see it you didn't
feel it you didn't touch it and you
don't know if you could believe the
reviews but even more than that uh in
the whole one huge category of
e-commerce is fashion and apparel and in
that
fit is the number one thing like you
know you're wearing a black fitted shirt
right now it fits you very well
but you don't know are you a large an
extra large a medium in different brands
it's always different
and isn't that just like kind of a crazy
thing that we just don't know what size
we should buy like that's like the
stupidest reason
for that it's crazy it counts for like
40 of returns or something ridiculous
like that right like i think it's crazy
returns account for like you know
somewhere between i don't know three and
ten percent uh you know of revenue for
these brands and then of the reasons for
returns it's not that it was defective
it just didn't fit right
and so what how do we solve this problem
okay so i invested in this company bolt
that does one click checkout and it's
basically like hey why do you have to
type your freaking card and address in
every single time
if you do it once we should just let you
check out again saving that and you know
you don't have to create an account with
every single merchant like
does it work for shopify
so shopify has their it has their own
called shop pay and amazon has their own
one click checkout this is bolt the
reason it works is because it's for
everybody else if you are not on shopify
you're not you're not named amazon
then you probably want to offer the same
level of like frictionless checkout
but um you can't get people to make an
account with your little leather boots
company you know maybe they made it with
this jacket company and now they should
just be able to check out at the boot
company even though the jack and the
boot company are two separate things all
right so bolt is kicking ass and it's
multi-billion dollar company already and
they made checkout more frictionless
okay so how do i make deciding to check
out more frictionless so here's my idea
i think you got to have a brick and
mortar location i think you basically
put up pop-up stores a court you put up
actually like nice kind of showroom
style stores
in la you know sf new york you just go
through all the major cities go to the
top 20 cities and you open up in
downtown
a fitting booth and it's called the
perfect fit or true fit and what is true
fit so you go in and this thing is going
to measure you
head to toe using the whatever the best
goddamn technology is in the world for
scanning a body and knowing its exact
dimensions like a tailor measuring your
crotch and all that it's going to
basically measure you automatically like
a when we get like a dexa scan or
something like that you go lay down in
this thing and it's going to measure you
for five minutes and now
you have your true fit and any store you
go to you could just
log in with your true fit uh or just
saved in your browser and saved on your
phone and basically it just gives the
store your exact it knows what your
exact sizes and fit is and maybe even
your preferred fit like do you like
things tighter or looser yeah do you
like it you know baggy around the
stomach or tighter on the stomach right
like maybe you even have that level of
preference and then every store it's
like an api so every store would just
say oh cool like just like we all have
the metric system we have this like
standardized system that we can say oh i
can i know how to describe the length of
my thing
because i can use the metric system i
can use inches or millimeters or
whatever it's going to be depending on
which system you use but we have these
central systems so i think we need one
for fit
and i think if you created this you
could just say you come in you get
scanned for free
and now you're going to have better
fitting stuff better fitting shoes
clothes jackets all that stuff on every
website you visit and then you go to the
websites and you say hey would you like
people to return less of your stuff
would you like them to know exactly what
size to get without having to go
look at your size chart and then go
measure the you know how many inches
their chest is like yeah that's really
ridiculous
and so now you just ping the system the
system says this person should be a
large in your in your stock in your
clothing uh and your your brand so
that's the idea what do you think of
this so i think it's amazing let me let
me
one thing look up zozo's suit z-o-z-o
suit
i've seen this before the this is it's
the motion detector thing it's like they
send you this black suit right well how
does this work
it's a rich guy right doesn't this
billionaire create this yeah so i'm i'm
going off memory
i think it was four or five or six years
ago
and it was a guy in japan he was a
successful entrepreneur i think in the
clothing space i think he owned some
type of like fast casual japanese
clothing company right and he created
this suit and it was either free or like
five dollars and basically it's a body
suit so if you've ever seen like behind
the scenes of uh of like loiter rings
when they're filming on the green screen
or have you ever seen like a bob like a
bobsledder or something like how they
have the suits that go over their head
it looks like that but it's all black
and has polka dots all over it and you
put it on and then you hold it up your
camera up to it your phone and it's
supposed to like figure out the
dimensions of your body and he was gonna
mail one of these to like everyone in
japan or something like that and it
failed i don't know why it failed i just
don't think it worked that great yeah
however
that are you looking it up when was that
now was it like five years ago yeah i
don't know where the time frame is or
this but i remember you told me about
this multiple years ago because you were
like dude i thought it was amazing crazy
and so i thought this was such a good
idea and there was people uh so i used
to go to uh great.com i think it's still
going october 29th 2020 so last year one
year ago they launched the zozo suit two
um so you know they're still going with
this
i think it's great and i remember going
on reddit and i would like on reddit
there was these subreddits where you
could buy and sell like fancy clothing
and i would buy and sell clothing on
there and there was these guys that
would kind of bootleg it where they
would download the app and then use the
the suit to just like get their own
measurements and then they would just
like write that down and then they would
like use that as like their way to
do sizing and i actually think that the
suit would
i don't know the technology behind it i
think you could do a better job though
than what you're describing and it's
freaking amazing if it works right um
but it i i don't know if it worked well
but if it does work the idea of this is
awesome and people were also using it
athletes were using it for their like
body measurements and you could like use
it to see if your muscles are growing or
not growing additionally there's this
one scale that never really took off but
they had a kickstarter and when i saw it
it was amazing but it was a little too
expensive for me to try before it got
built and basically it was a scale that
looked like a normal
bathroom scale you stand on it but then
this arm came out and it does it like
there's arm that comes out the bottom
and it does a loop around your body and
like wraps around your body and it would
use a camera to
scan your body and they would tell you
all about if your measurements are going
up or down i thought that was amazing i
love those things um and i thought that
that would do do you remember that scale
yeah i know what you're talking about
it's called like naked or something
something like that
um didn't didn't seem to catch on but uh
i think there's something here yeah it's
called naked
nakedlabs.com and i think yeah i think i
think it's harder to do as a startup i
actually think that this is better to do
if you're amazon or or your bolt like
this might be my free idea for bolt hey
hey guys here's what you should do
uh you've raised hundreds of millions of
dollars you should
you know you might have to pour 40 50
million dollars into developing this
network of stores that has this
technology that basically all day is
just measuring customers but it's also
in this case it would be driving
people to put in their information so
now they can just check out bolt
anywhere and um you know you're on file
but you did not just have their payment
info on file but you'd have their size
info on file so now i would buy so much
more stuff bolt becomes more valuable to
every merchant because it not only
stores payments but it has their
customer fit information and i also
think that this is not the easiest thing
so it's not just about scanning the body
because
you actually kind of need to see how the
clothes fit on somebody so you'd almost
want if you're gonna do this perfectly
and i don't know if it's a good idea or
not but you'd almost want like
10 shirts that are like the stock shirt
fits and it's like okay try these five
on
yeah that looks good on you do you like
how this fits yes okay you are um you
are a size medium specifically this many
centimeters uh you know all your or your
measurements are here and you prefer the
fit of x so we know how to translate
that now to any brand how any brand can
use that
against our standardized measurement
system and so um so i feel like this is
kind of an impractical idea but i just
wish it worked because it would reduce
friction so much in shopping it would
make people way more willing to shop so
way less returns
we asked mark lori mark lori was the guy
sir jud.com sold it to walmart for some
many billions and we asked him what's an
idea that you would work on right now if
you wanted to sell it a hundred million
dollars and two or three this is it
right this is what he said and this was
it he said he goes the the number one
problem the number one um cost that our
company has at wal you know walmart.com
the third or fourth or second most
popular econ website in the world the
number one thing is returns due to bad
sizes so if you figure out a way just to
help us save that just a little bit we
would pay a whole lot of money for that
right and
you know you actually could do this
where you could if you weren't techy you
could just open up small shops that were
like two or three thousand dollars a
month in rent have two tailors there
and um and then go out to some of the
bigger
retailer brands and be like hey will you
put our
our uh
our logo on your site and help us and
there's scrappy ways to do this you
might be able to partner with existing
stores and you just have it you just
have like a booth and you have an agent
there who can do it uh so you may not
even need the space but all right this
is one that's one idea okay let me give
you another idea uh future of shopping
continued
so
um
i don't remember where i heard this but
i heard somebody's talking about this
and i just it was like a
no-brainer moment for me okay so
we all know that like
you know software keeps getting better
robots keep getting better
and it's sort of like uh what's gonna
happen to all these trucking jobs if
they're self-driving trucks what's gonna
happen all these retail like check
cashier jobs if uh you know like the
amazon go store where you just walk in
you pick up an item and you walk out
and it just knows from what you picked
up off the shelf how much to charge your
amazon account right like kind of
amazing and i think
those are two of the most popular jobs
in america as truck driver and um like
retail cashier and so uh okay what what
what is like even further down this so
here's the easy one that i thought was
kind of cool
um restaurant drive-throughs so
restaurant drive-throughs you know you
go you pull up you roll down your window
and they say oh yeah welcome to
mcdonald's what can i get for you today
and you're like um you know and let me
get the number three they're like you
know what do you want to drink blah blah
blah
so why do you know what a number three
at mcdonald's is
a number three at mcdonald's i'm gonna
go with a double cheeseburger what is it
i think it's a double cheeseburger or a
quarter pounder number one's a bigger
neck it's probably quarter pounder
number two is the two cheeseburgers that
was my that was my order
number three is quarter pounder i'm more
of a chicken sandwich kind of guy so
that's what i get that's like a separate
thing yeah yeah
there's like the shitty fried one that's
like the eight and then there's like the
kind of like less fried one
artisanal one yeah there's one with like
a tomato on top now you're healthy um so
so the the idea here is like why does
that person have to be in the store
like they don't they don't right like we
have zoom we're doing this podcast in
two different cities you know 100 miles
apart um why can't
why does that per why isn't that person
just at home on zoom just taking orders
from me in every location so there's no
down time
all right we talked about this before
there's these things that look like
segways but with like an ipad screen on
it and there's like a woman who you
could like talk to and she's like
rolling around the store those have
never taken off they've never taken off
they've never taken off i know why by
the way we had one in our office uh so
we had like one of those programs it's
called the double it's called double
robotics it's the name of the company
and at first it's like oh wow this is
cool like you could be working remotely
but you're like you're the remote
manager and you're just wheeling up
behind people's desks and you're like
hey
hey how's it going and then they turn
your faces on the ipad
and like for for for real simple reasons
it doesn't work which is like hey it
can't go upstairs so if you have like
any stair in any of any part of your
office they just can't get there i can't
like open doors um you know so if you
have like a meeting room it can't get in
uh like the ipad would die and it's like
ah [__] ipad's dead right now okay we're
gonna have to go charge this never mind
just just call me and like that happens
three times and then you just start
skipping the robotics thing because
you're like just call me dude like we
always end up on the call anyways for
one of these five reasons and uh so just
skip that whole step so it never really
took off but it was too complicated it
was too fancy
the drive-through thing you you don't
even see the person anyways they're
literally just a speaker
no there's a speaker in the wall when
you give them money you do yeah because
that's a separate person right that's
that's like that's their other job you
know that's like they do this other
thing you know and while they're trying
to give you their change of talking to
the next person in line
this should just be
like imagine the downtime so like you
know one of the reasons that like uber
is expensive is because there's a whole
bunch of time that a human is driving
around without a passenger right because
they're driving from one trip to the
next same thing happens in
drive-throughs there's like there's like
time in between cars in between orders
but if i was remotely i could be working
at five locations at once and anytime
somebody has a person there i just hop i
just connect to that screen i talk to
them i connect to the next stream
there's no down time
there's this crazy stat where i think
it's like one in 16 americans have
worked at a mcdonald's have you ever
heard that no but i believe it
it's something like 1 in 16. you know
mcdonald's is one of the largest
employers in the world and it's
basically like they call it like
like internally or even externally like
when you're applying for a job there
they call it like the world's greatest
first job and so like the whole shtick
is like we're really good for
just we know you don't want to be here
forever
yeah
and they embrace it and i think that's
smart and when i think about my my aunt
i um i have an aunt who's been a cashier
at a grocery store for
uh 40 years that's just was her job she
still is and when i think about this
stuff about the self-checkouts and not
having someone there uh at drive-through
and how like i i'm almost positive it's
one in 16 americans it's something
shockingly high i have worked at
mcdonald's
do you think that you have an obligation
as an employer to continue doing some of
these minimum wage jobs just so you
exist to like
further society along otherwise if that
isn't the case then you got you're gonna
have to do some type of universal income
or something like that
yeah it's gonna be creative destruction
and it's gonna be
rocky before it gets good and i think
you have to let the progress happen so
you know here's how this is going to go
today in california they're paying you
know like if you go look at any
mcdonald's or chipotle or whatever it's
like now hiring please please [__]
come work here 24 an hour and it's like
wow 24 an hour for this like this is not
a minimum wage job that's like three
times the minimum wage so and they're
still having trouble with getting people
to come work there
california is like 15 california's
higher now but it's still double it's
like double the minimum wage and so uh
and that's for mcdonald's so what does
that mean you know that's just going to
cause prices to go up or it's going to
cause some stores to close because
they're just not economical when you
have crazy labor costs and so um so
what's going to happen is that's going
to go to first they're going to do the
remote thing that i talked about which
is instead of paying somebody 24 in
california they're gonna find somebody
in nebraska who can zoom in and say can
i take your order
um as long as they can say can i take
your order and push a button then and
they're willing to do it for twelve
dollars from at home that's gonna happen
and then that's gonna get replaced
because they're gonna be like i'm tired
of paying the schmuck twelve dollars
what uh oh amazon just released its
alexa product for all brands and i can
just uh
i can just have it be like an alexa
where it just asks a question and then
just auto like figures out what i want
um
cool like just like at airports you know
people checking at kiosks now instead of
at the front desk like the companies are
going to go this way they're going to go
towards automation because it just makes
too much financial sense i don't think
you should get in the way of progress
but are you are you bored with remote
work
no
dude i'm so [__] bored
i'm so bored i like you i miss people i
miss hanging out like i miss it so much
i feel like i have way less friends
right now
um i miss it so much i am so bored and
like i find myself going to target like
three days a week just to walk around
and like see stuff i go to whole foods
like all the time like i purposely won't
go like once every two weeks or once
every 10 days for a big trip i'll do
lots of small errands i go to the corner
store all the time i find myself just
like going i'm like let's go shop i just
need to get out and i need to be around
people and if the people went away from
that i would also be pretty bummed um
that i would be pretty bummed out well i
think it would just shift right like
okay so now with all this free time what
do you go do you go do something else
and so you go do something else that
gives you that people hit uh you'll
you'll unbundle
the socializing part from the
like cashier part you know like okay the
cashier can become a robot so i'm gonna
get my people
my people hit from something else and i
actually think there's gonna be a whole
new job
that is just basically like software
supervisor
like i just think that's gonna be a job
like software is going to replace what a
lot of people do but then it's going to
get stuck and it's not going to know how
to solve some problem or it's not going
to understand somebody's accent at the
drive-thru and then you as the
supervisor are going to step in and say
hey human here yeah i can help you out
sorry about that sorry this stupid
software doesn't work well and uh i
don't want this to exist i hate i hate
that i hate it i hate it but i i i agree
it's inevitable inevitable for sure and
i think there's a whole set of jobs
called software supervisor or like robot
repair or like robot manager you're just
gonna manage robots it's like what is my
job i used to have to walk around and
pick up these things now this machine in
this warehouse goes and picks up
everything i just have to watch the
machine to make sure it doesn't hit
something else and if it gets stuck or
it needs you know some grease i go
grease it because i'm a robot manager
that's what i do and that's going to
become the normal job
yeah i agree with you i think it's going
to happen um
can i show you something cool really
quick yeah what else you got
all right ben hit it
[Music]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool
a billion dollars
[Music]
all right we got an interesting segment
you like that this is billy of the week
we're gonna i'm gonna talk to you sean
about this guy named brian johnson um i
showed you this guy um let me give you a
little bit of background about who about
who this is and i'm not actually going
to talk about his business so brian
johnson started a company called
braintree if you are an entrepreneur or
you work in like ecom or anything that
takes payment braintree's you probably
know what it is it's a payment gateway
it's basically stripe but different
uh he bootstrapped the company for a
long time raised a little bit of money
once it was already quite successful and
then sold it for
a huge amount of money and this was like
five years ago i believe they also
bought venmo braintree but
yeah solid to paypal and if i had to
guess at this point he's probably worth
at least a billion um that's how much
money he made i think he sold it for
like six or seven or even
yeah it was 300 he sold it for 300 a few
hundred million yeah so something like
300 more like 300 i think
oh got it okay so he's in the range
maybe he's very wealthy so this guy is
incredibly interesting and because he
just launched something called blueprint
so if you go to
blueprint.brianjohnson.com his name is
brian
b-r-y-a-n brian johnson
he's doing something pretty amazing
basically he's
spending all of his time right now
trying to lower his biological age so
his chronological age his real age i
think is 45 his biological age is 35 and
he's measuring all 70 plus of his organs
he's measuring
nobody knows what this is what what the
heck is a crime so chronological age is
the number of years you're alive
right that's that's what that is yeah
and then what biological age is what
yeah so frankly i don't i'm not entirely
aware of how they measure it but i know
that i have one using i use this site
that huberman who was on our podcast
promote it it's called inside tracker
and it tracks your blood and different
parts of your body and it tells you what
your biological age is and i think they
do that by
looking at the averages so
but frankly i'm not sure but they
basically like you can be 50 years old
but have the body of a 40 year old and
this biological age thing it's like a
standard way of measuring but i don't
know what all goes into it
and so you're right 800 million is what
he sold it for okay so i'm on 800. so
you were right about that so let's go to
this guy's thing which is by the way
this guy's doing something else too he's
basically creating um like a neural link
which is like the same thing elon musk's
trying to do it's like a brilliant it
looks like a helmet and you could like
think something and it happens
exactly so you can think like it can
just read your brain waves and it can
cause something they can type out a text
message off of a thought that'd be
that'd be the dream or the idea and this
new thing is this blog where basically
he's basically measuring
everything in his body and he said
lebron james said he spent 1.5 million
dollars a year to improve his body i'm
spending more than that
i've developed all the tests i've got as
much money as you could possibly have my
whole goal here is to lower my
biological age and i test all my organs
and when i test them i put all the
results here so anyone could do it and
he lists his diet his workout everything
and he listed his diet let me just read
what he had for breakfast breakfast was
super veggie he basically had broccoli
cauliflower spinach
mushrooms garlic
and salt and vinegar ugh that was his
breakfast lunch
lunch leafy greens veggies berries seeds
and nuts dinner was nutty pudding i
don't know what that is almond milk
macadamia nuts
chia seeds blueberry raspberries
pomegranate juice that's it
and then he lists all of his supplements
children's hemoglobin uh
yeah he's like eating like crazy stuff
and he's jacked so he's 165 pounds he's
probably only 5 10 6 foot so he's not
like huge but he's i think six percent
body fat he has his body fat all there
and he has like all i don't know how you
you know i don't you can click through
this and you can see all of the
attributes to each organ and things like
that um so i don't understand a lot of
it but it's incredibly fascinating and i
think it's fascinating because a i just
think this is interesting but b
i think
i've been saying this for a little while
what this guy is doing is going to be
very common not in five years but like
maybe in 15 or 20 or 30 years and the
reason why i've always thought that this
is weird and this is like the biggest
problem one of the biggest problems we
have as humans
is basically
how often have you heard the story of
like
a person just found out that they have
cancer
and it's like stage five stage four or
whatever had they known it could have
been cured and it's freaking crazy how
reactive we are to health and not
proactive and so i actually think that
what he's doing which is proactive it's
going to be the future i don't think
it's going to be this extreme because
like i've always said this like even
though like
you know drugs are bad like you still
got to get [__] up sometimes so you
can't be eating [__] macadamia nuts
and chicago mushrooms every goddamn meal
like you know what i mean you got to
have some cake and like some tequila
once in a while so like i'm down to get
[__] up once in a while but i do think
that like this is pretty cool
this is amazing uh i can't believe i
haven't seen this before so it's new
it's this is like two months old
this is one of the most amazing things
i've ever seen i'm just clicking through
right now and like i don't want to do
this podcast i want to go read
all of this and i want to see what's
amazing right so there's i i totally
agree with you that um
the future looks more like this than it
does like today
so uh like it is crazy that we don't
know what's going on inside our own body
in fact there's a question that you can
ask yourself
which gets you to think a little bit
differently and see the world a little
differently which is in 50 years
like today all right let's say we look
back 100 years ago so 100 years ago was
the year 1920
and um
how many things in our day how many
things that that they did back then
would just seem so primitive right so
it's like
um okay but did you say 50 years ago was
1920 100 years ago so 100 years ago 1920
right so let's say um 100 years ago i
don't know what what's i don't know the
exact timeline of things but like uh you
know 1920 like
uh alcohol it just happened
yeah so uh smoking was far more common
you could advertise cigarettes to people
you could smoke you could smoke anywhere
you want so that was quite common
um like there's a whole bunch of things
like so all the things we do like if i
look at my day today it's like well no
there was no internet there's definitely
no cell phone there was definitely no i
don't even think there was um
like i don't even know like could women
vote like i don't i don't know when all
these things happen but like it was just
happening right around then world looked
very different let's put it that way so
uh world looked very different
and um
and you know but it looked it felt
completely normal at the time and so
and so if you if you think about if you
go forward you say okay cool so then you
know um you fast forward to today and
then you go forward a hundred years so
you know when i look back and i see
slavery i say wow that's crazy i can't
believe that was i was okay or you know
the hot when the holocaust was happening
i can't believe people just stood by
while that happened
and it's like what are the holocausts of
today and it's like i think so for
personally for example i believe that
people will look back and be like you
just killed animals all the time you
just murdered them
for food like you murdered them for
lunch for that number seven i don't
think we're gonna we're gonna do it
we're gonna we're not gonna necessarily
do it about that but i think what they
will say is so you would just like raise
these chickens like a million of them
under this barn and they would be
[__] on each other and like you just
like or these cows they're like born
into this pen and straight from the pen
they go straight to the butcher where
they're killed as a veal like you
treated them that way so the mom never
like i think that we're going to be like
i can't believe you i think that's how
people people are starting to feel that
now right that's like where you know
like a lot of the kind of vegan
plant-based stuff comes from is you see
what's going on in a farm you're like
this is horrible um
the horrible from like a moral ethical
level you know like i like
for example my wife's vegan and i was
like yeah okay you know like i get it
killing animals to eat them is probably
not good right that is killing a live
thing and like i love my dog and if i
spend time with like a horse i kind of
like love that horse too like
cows you know like they're not that far
they're not that different right like
um yeah i guess i could see how if i had
to if i had to like think about it
emotionally that would be feel really
wrong okay but what about you know just
like having milk and eggs it can't be
that bad right like what's wrong with
milk and i love cheese what's wrong with
cheese
and then they showed that like uh you
know like you know earmuffs if you if
you're sensitive you can't handle the
stuff but basically
the way that the way that the videos i
was watching that were like how how they
get milk it's like
milk basically a cow gives birth to a
baby they then separate the baby from
the mom they put it like nearby enough
where the where the mom can hear the
baby crying for milk but it can't reach
it so the milk gets produced like at
this like much higher rate or whatever
and first of all to even get them
pregnant they like artificially
inseminate them they like basically like
rape them with their arm with a plastic
bag over it and uh they just keep them
pregnant year round so they're just
constantly pregnant in order to
constantly be producing milk and then
they're constantly taking the babies
away to cry and then they go kill the
baby
for food and then they let the mom just
keep milking so it's like yeah it's a
pretty messed up thing you know like
if once you know it's pretty hard to uh
i'm down i'm down to kill him to eat him
i just i would like to treat him a
little nicer before we kill him what i'm
saying is that's going to be like that's
going to be like you know i that's going
to be seen like i i like my house slave
like i treat them well like i feed them
i think that's how it's going to be seen
100 years ago i think the way we treat
animals today dude we've been eating
animals since the beginning of time i
don't think it's going to change it's
going to change you're on drugs i think
we're going to feed them nicer
it's going to change because we're going
to have a good substitute which is lab
grown meat so people are going to be
able to make make the make the same
steak you want without killing the
animal and then in that case killing the
animal is going to look absolutely
barbaric it's going to be only a hobby
sport it is not going to be the way you
feed feed the population so god i think
you are so wrong about this okay fair
enough but there is a thought experiment
that i believe that in hundreds but i i
think we are going to treat it
i think we're going to treat them better
i totally think that that's why i
remember trying to buy
yes before we murder them yeah dude i'm
i'm higher up in the in the food chain
i'm going to eat you i think um i've
been trying to buy a cow here have you
ever you know you could buy like a whole
cow like i you can drive to the farm
here in austin and like see like the
farm and then you pay like ten dollars
or eight dollars
yeah and you could like buy the cow i've
been trying to do that because i
i think that's a good way to do it but
it's i have so okay anyways so my point
is there's you can think of a whole
bunch of things one what else is going
to seem barbaric i think the health
thing that you're talking about right
now which is that you can't you don't
know what's going on in your body at any
given time
like it's [__] crazy [__] crazy
they're gonna be like so you just you
were just winging it it's like yeah you
know we go to the doctor like once a
year and we just say hey
is everything all right once i said
you've been to the doctor bro dude don't
go to the doctor dude then don't go to
the doctor i've been a doctor in like
five years i've made an appointment and
i missed it because i was late you know
i'm late to everything i'm late to this
podcast i was late to the doctor and he
could yeah like
i haven't seen a dentist in like 20
years for sure a dentist you can miss me
with that so there's basically like you
know there's no point but but i'm down
to have like some chip in my body or
some blood sensor that's like
i want to at all times know what's going
on my body i just don't want to go to
the doctor so um that's going to be seen
as crazy that we it's like people who
it's like if you go drive around without
a map or something it's like whoa where
you renegade
we're going to be seen as the ultimate
renegades for having just like lived
life
not knowing when there's cancers and
blood diseases that are just floating
around in our body and like
hope we caught it in time you know oh we
didn't that's too bad you know it's
crazy to me so have you heard of the um
the the mayo executive health clinic or
the health check i've been thinking
about doing it it's like i'm gonna do it
i'll do it with you explain it it's like
five grand let's use our uh let's use
our and our nft money and do it so
basically yeah yeah let's do that it's
five or six thousand dollars and it's
posted by the mayo clinic and they have
locations in probably where's mayo
indiana i think notre dame is that notre
dame and i think they have another one
arizona
arizona is the closest one is it arizona
but describe what it is because i didn't
know about this until buddy told me and
i was like oh [__] yeah we should do
that yeah i've been thinking about doing
it but i wasn't sure if it'd be
beneficial to me at my age i thought
maybe it would be more beneficial a
little bit older but basically you spend
five to eight grand and you go to this
mayo clinic a hospital ultimately uh in
arizona and you stay there for two
nights three days and they just do a ton
of tests on you so you get mri done you
get all your blood work done you get
i don't even know i mean you just they
have a list if you type in mayo
executive
health checkup or something they have it
and basically in order to get so when we
sold the company i had to get this thing
called um
and even before we sold it i had to get
it because we were big enough to where
like if sam if me if i got sued it could
be bad for the company and so we would
get this thing called uh board of
directors insurance have you heard of
that yep yep and so it's cheap it's like
a thousand dollars or five i forget how
much it costs and if you're a little bit
older
um or you're unhealthy it's what i think
sometimes you have to get one of these
cl one of these things done in order to
qualify for that health insurance or to
get a discount on it and uh basically
you go to this place and they do a ton
of different [__] on you just to see
like what your health how healthy you
are and you're supposed to go once a
year right
and so you do uh does it say what the
scans are so
there's a bunch of preventatives what
they are yeah like cardiovascular okay
whatever this is not gonna tell us
anything uh but they test for like you
know like metals in your body or like
other [__] that like you don't get at
the normal doctor
and it sounds like you know
over the top like i really wouldn't
really think about it but the person who
recommended it they were like hey um
like you know we're now like all like 30
plus and um like you know [__] happens
like
hopefully not in your 30s sometimes in
your 40s
getting to your 50s 60s 70s it becomes
like a probably type of thing
and they're like you know we've been
fortunate to make some money like the
best use we can do of our money is
health and so like let's just do this
thing let's just do it every year we'll
make a fun trip out of it and uh let's
go get this screen done and like let's
just stay yeah he's trying to get he's
been trying to get ramon to do it i'll
do it i'll i'm gonna do it yeah so so we
should uh we should book this thing so
let's go back to this brian johnson
thing okay so
he is basically monitoring his body at
an extreme level and it looks like he's
basically measuring
the health and age of his organs
of his individual organs and then he's
looking at if i take this you know
30 micrograms of melatonin before bed
how does that affect x it's like you
know the quantified self nerd stuff but
on
steroids on you know on like
this is like the most extreme example
i've seen of it
it's the most extreme example i don't
think it's a good way to live because
like it
it's it's uh you have
you probably don't have that much joy
no no this isn't for the normal person
this is for the
like the human population needs like
point one percent of the beginning yeah
to be this weird and do these tests and
push the boundaries and like live in the
future like there's that phrase
um i forgot what it is i have a
simplified version of it the simplified
ver the complicated version is like the
futures future is already here it's just
not evenly distributed um but i just say
the future is really it's just not
everywhere which is like the simple way
of saying that right like it's like this
guy's living in the future we're just
not all living in the future right now
like the thing he's doing we will all
know this level of detail about our
bodies i've heard uh a phrase it's like
basically what rich nerds do on the
weekend everyone will be doing in 10
years right
yeah and that's exactly what this is uh
this is amazing have you seen a picture
of him look look at look at his like
look at him without by the way this is
like yeah he's insane so he's six feet
tall he's 40 something years old and
he's 3.5 percent body fat he's insanely
ripped but he's always good and he said
that
he said that wasn't optimal he goes that
was too low so i went back up to like
6.8 yeah
yeah it's pretty sick click that video i
found six point eight low so i went to
26.
look there's a picture of him there's a
video of him dunking or like jumping up
there heavy
like he looks great man this guy looks
super good
he is to me like you know like elon musk
gets a ton of worship because it's like
wow you're the
genius billionaire inventor and you like
say dick jokes like you're my hero um
and it's not that this guy's like better
than elon or elon's worse than this guy
nothing really like that but man i love
finding these guys that are like
they're not like
they're they're no different like this
guy is just as smart
has been super successful
he is absolutely ripped which like you
know something like elon has not been
prioritizing that you could tell so it's
like this guy lives a different
lifestyle but it's like this guy will
have one one millionth the fame of elon
musk right now you know what i mean like
if i go look this elon musk i think he's
got 2 000 followers on twitter let's i'm
going to dm him yeah like we should have
him on because i think this guy's
fascinating and like we've actually
talked about it before by the way we did
him as billy the week before this
because he told the story about
door-to-door sales and i went on this
long rant about door-to-door sales and
how i thought that was like an amazing
hack for hiring anybody who's done well
with door-to-door sales so elon musk 63
million followers
brian johnson i think he's like two
three four five thousand
yeah like uh let's see
he's okay he's at twenty seven thousand
so he's not nothing but in twenty seven
thousand sixty three million
is uh like uh i think he got a bunch
because he went on the lex freeman
podcast and
that like really boosted him but yeah
he's basically like you know one one
thousand uh more than one thousand times
less famous but i think these types of
people are like way more accessible way
more interesting to learn from and just
more fun to be a fan of than just being
a fan of you know the yankees type of
thing
yeah all right let's get them on it's
this guy's fascinating um
he he's very interesting and uh ben by
the way he's a mormon right so uh
so ben you're basically related to him
ask your cousin if he'll come on then
yeah don't you know him
um
all i can say is i'll see what i can do
yeah like
you definitely you definitely have a
cousin isn't there like a group chat
basketball camp with him or something 15
million of us one group chat yeah
yeah
like your social network or something
you you surely have you have something
just for this we do have a social
network actually no one uses it but we
do have one
what is it what's it called
i don't even know
just tabernacles
it's a it's a it's an app that was made
by the church by the church called
nature yeah
i'll look that can be uh next episode
i'll tell you all about the yeah just
the church app just column sounds like a
business opportunity if the mormon
social network exists but nobody's
really using it i feel like all you got
to do is you know airdrop some tokens
and uh and all of a sudden people will
be using this thing like
yeah by the way did you get either guys
you guys don't own uh by the way just
ask mitt romney for an intro
he knows him
she is yeah
there's definitely a group chat for like
the successful super successful mormons
they all took the blood out oath
do you know what an airdrop is
no i see everyone talking about it and
i'm too afraid to ask
okay so basically an airdrop is this
amazing thing in crypto where you just
wake up and then there's thousands of
dollars in your wallet that you didn't
have the day before and so that's what
happened yesterday is anybody who owned
uh what's called a dot ens the ethereum
name service which is basically like a
you know you could have dot com dot org
dot io
there's a dot ens now and so like when i
did my crypto week i was like oh i want
to have my like my name space in the in
the on the blockchain like the ethereum
world so i created a a e s like how much
money did you get so i got like four
grand yesterday just for having i only
have one i have friends that have like
hundreds of these names they they made
like fifty thousand hundred thousand
dollars yesterday
uh just
you know you you bought this thing like
you know i paid a hundred dollar gas fee
or two hundred dollars of gas fees to
get my name
and uh you know that thing paid off with
like a 4 000 airdrop so basically the
the organization that's behind this they
created their own token yesterday for
that will be used to like vote on
how this thing works so like in the
domain world there's like i can you know
what i mean like it's this this is
committee called i can and i can gets to
decide
when there's a new domain which is
[__] like dot photo or dot business
sub dot dot is such [__] so
that's the governing body right and so
with with the crypto world it's
decentralized so the way it works is
everybody who owns a name gets to vote
so if you're if you're a user you get to
vote and so how do you vote you vote
with your tokens and so they dropped
they airdropped a bunch of tokens to to
everybody and so everybody made a bunch
of money nobody's going to care about
the vote it's like reading the privacy
policy of a website you're just like
yeah yeah agree agree agree sure i'll
i'll vote with the majority no problem
just give me my give me my free money
please uh but this happens all the time
in the in the crypto world is if you own
an asset the group that made that can
airdrop
more tokens to you and those have some
market value uh associated with them
like that happened with board apes if
you had a board ape
they airdropped you this potion
that you could give your ape and turn it
into a mutant and that potion and the
mutants basically it just like doubled
the value of whatever you own so you
owned a thing that was worth i think the
cheapest one right now is like 150 000
it's at the time they were like 50 000
and you be people were basically getting
a free 10 to 20 dollar item air dropped
to them by the organization it's kind of
insane
now that bitcoin's 67 grand what um
how much your net worth is in crypto
i don't even calculate it anymore like i
don't know i don't care over 50 percent
uh probably yeah probably because you
know i basically started it my goal was
to put in 25 i think put i put 20 in
and then i started going up so much i
just i stopped at 20. and uh you know i
should have just gone all in i should
have gone all in like i believed and i
should have gone to 80
what about what do you think what do you
think pomp has how much crypto do you
think he has
he says he was 90 crypto but i don't
think he had a ton of money at the time
and the question i have is like he then
started making easily
a few million dollars a year over the
last let's say three years
i wouldn't say easily
i would say
i would say two to three million a year
if i had to guess right right so that's
a few million dollars a year for the
last couple years so that's like let's
say
after taxes and all that good stuff
let's say he got another four or five
million bucks
out of
um
you know all of his content sponsorships
and all that good stuff courses that
sort of thing
the question is did he
convert all that into bitcoin as he was
going or did he hedge
uh if he converted it all
you know that means he's got
i would if i was gonna place a guess i
would say that if he
when he was earning that bitcoin's gone
up about 5x since then so if you had
four million dollars gone 5x that's
about a 20 million dollar stake at that
part not not including whatever you had
before that
so i would guess the guy's net worth is
probably
i'd set the line at 30 million dollars
the liquid net worth um not including
good not not only the ownership of the
startup studies startup investments that
he made that are you know speculative
and illiquid at the moment
yeah i mean that'd be a home run but
that could be awesome what do you think
would you guess that
i'd probably say lower if i had a guess
i've got no information if i had to
guess i would say 15
15. um and i think when he started the
like um
the like before he was pumped the brand
name
you know like a lot of it depends on
what was your base right so like well he
said in his art he wrote this amazing
article about how he's quitting um yeah
that was fun
it was a great article you shared it as
like uh just great writing and i agree
with you i think you shared it yeah um
and it was really good and so basically
pomp's came on our pod a couple times we
should have him on again um and he is
this personality who has a sub stack has
a podcast has a a fund where he raised i
think a hundred million dollars and he
basically it was with 100
i don't know if it was 100 but yeah go
ahead something well tens of millions
let's say he wrote a letter to his
investors saying i'm shutting this down
because i want more free time and i want
to spend more time doing what i want so
here's your money back he goes i don't
want to be a billionaire i want to be a
time billionaire
and i love that i completely agree with
that move that's totally the right move
he basically said without saying that i
was unhappy because i was addicted to
screens and i don't want to be like on
this dopamine game anymore which is so
common we've been hearing that
constantly we're hearing that a lot not
surprising the pendulum is swinging
right we all got addicted to this
substance
and now you know some of us are coming
off of it publicly
uh
i read it a little bit differently
here's how i read it i read it like this
which is
it doesn't really make sense for me to
invest y'all's money now because i kind
of got enough money on my own that i'm
just going to invest my own money and
not have to deal with any of you guys
and i don't need to like play this game
of fees and carry
when um which will just make me want to
like i have to raise this bigger and
bigger fund deal with more of you guys
have to like deploy more and more
capital which takes more time like
if i just invest my own money at this
point i'm going to do much better i'll
make more money because i'll own 100 of
my upside
and secondly
i don't have to keep i don't have to
deal with any people i don't have to
deal with anybody i don't have to go
fundraise i don't have to write updates
i don't have to do any of this stuff
um so i kind of read it which was just
like
that made
when i was famous but not rich
it was great to raise a fund and that
was the only way i could invest a bunch
of money but now i'm rich and famous and
so i don't need your money anymore
because it comes with problems right
like it comes with
has your
has your mini fame exhausted you
no not at all
but i don't even really i don't even
feel that famous uh at all so i don't
like it you're like all the time to do
[__] yeah but i just say no i just say
no all the time so like i me too but i
find it to be tiring like it keeps me up
it like for example this young guy i
lived next to a university this kid
knocked on my door last week and he goes
hey i was wondering do you have a dog
like i want to make some extra money uh
i would walk your dog for you and i said
[__] egg good hustle i appreciate
that i'm not just going to give my dog
to you though write up a letter tell me
all about yourself and put it in here
and i'll determine if i think you're a
good fit and he did it and i've been
losing sleep each because i'm like i
don't need someone to walk my dog but
like i want to give this guy a little
bit of money how should i say i've been
like keeping up at night like it's been
keeping me up at night for like five or
seven days on how i'm gonna like reply
to this guy and i get messages in email
and i'm like and sometimes i get it from
people i love and they want me to do
stuff and i'm like i don't want to do
this how do i say no you should just say
look uh
you know i would just be
you should just say completely exactly
what you're saying which is i think your
hustle was awesome which made me want to
say yes but i also realized i don't i
actually like walking my dog i don't
need somebody to walk my dog so let's do
this um i'm gonna pay you for a week of
walking my dog you don't have to walk my
dog um
because i want you to be rewarded for
what you're doing because i think it's
really great and i remember when i was
you
um so you know here's this money uh i
need to sleep easy at night and i also
want to walk my own dog and uh hey if
you ever want to like do something else
uh you know like maybe if i ever have
like a job for somebody who's who i need
a hustler to do something i got your
number
and uh just some of that you'll make his
day and then you'll be able to like
chill out and not have to think about it
yeah that's awesome i was gonna just i'm
just gonna venmo him like 50 bucks and
be like
uh i want to reward you
make it a magic moment for him so like
uh this is a game i've been playing and
i think you should do this as much as
you can i'm really just giving myself
this advice
which is
let's say there's a situation like this
and like you could give him you could
just say no
you could be nice and give him 50 bucks
but what would make it feel amazing is
like
probably just like a little bit more
than 50 bucks and
some message like the thing i just said
which will make him feel like oh [__]
this guy's awesome and like he re he saw
me for being awesome like i got
validated for this hustle that i was
doing um like there's tony robbins tells
the story of like he was in this
restaurant
and uh the waiter was great he was like
had a big big group it was like a big
family dinner and everybody needed a
different thing and the waiter was so
kind and he was just hustling and he was
making everybody laugh and he did this
magic trick for my daughter and like he
was this young kid 21 years old or
something like that
and he tells the story he's like
at the end of the dinner
i already knew like hey this waiter was
great and i'm gonna leave him a nice tip
but he said who would you say who did
you say did this tony robbins
and uh and his kid is like uh
somebody suggests something or he
realizes he's like you know what i'm not
just gonna leave him a tip what would
make this a magic moment for this kid
all right how can i do this he goes all
right guys
when this guy comes out with our with
our to-go boxes or whatever like the
final thing
we're gonna this guy's been amazing
right we all agree this waiter's been
amazing we were gonna give him a
standing ovation in this restaurant oh
my god and he's like gets the whole
table to stand up they just start
cheering for this guy as he's coming
forward he's like what is everything
okay he's like and then he just says he
goes i need to talk to your manager he's
like what i it brings the manager over
he says look uh you know i've been
coming to this restaurant for a long
time this is the best experience i've
had this waiter was amazing
and he really just made the night for
our family and i just want to thank you
for that thank you for hiring this kid
he just kind of like made the kid feel
like a star
and i think the story goes on which is
like i think his daughter ended up
marrying this guy or something like that
like it ended up being some crazy story
but just he he kind of left that nugget
he goes just think about what's the
little extra 10 20 you could do like it
didn't take that much more effort to
just like stand up and clap for the guy
like a little bit embarrassing i guess
but a little bit
unorthodox but it is
it didn't like require more money
or more time it was just a little
creativity of how to make this guy feel
like a little extra and uh and so i've
been doing that from time to time where
i'll just see a situation i'll go okay
dude you cheered you stood up and
cheered or you're like not in a
restaurant i haven't done anything i
didn't want to do the exact same thing
but i use this this idea of make it a
magic moment for the person
um and it's like you know i could just
do this that would be like the normal
good thing
but what would make this like really pop
off and what would make this something
that they will remember tonight they'll
go tell somebody that this happened for
them um and then i do that thing and i
never regret it it's always like
you know if my intention is good like
you know even if the
even if the execution is slightly
awkward i'd rather be the guy that does
that than uh is in the is in his shell
you know
i think i agree all right fine uh lucky
lucky kid i'll have to send him this
podcast
uh all right we should wrap it up and uh
yeah we're good
all right that's the episode
yeah
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back